let's go to our next caller from the
four to five area code four to five
who's this hello my name is Derrick
Busby and I'm actually farm Urbana
Illinois all right what's on your mind
today Derrick so there's a lot of talk
about how the Conservative Party's been
capturing all three branches of
government with the appointment coming
up of the Supreme Court and I remember
reading something about how Roosevelt
was able to possibly add people onto the
court and that the Constitution doesn't
necessarily say how many people could be
on the court that's true is that oh yeah
well just wondering your thought on that
I'm sorry okay so it looks like we had a
very very significant but short
interruption in the signal there yeah
this is part of court packing right and
we've talked about this a little bit and
I think we're going to talk about it
more the idea is that you sort of take
control back of the Supreme Court by
when you have the opportunity to add
increase the number of Justices you
could for example go from nine to eleven
and appoint those two additional and if
they are you know leftist judges then
you can regain control of the Supreme
Court and you know I've not looked into
exactly what the mechanism is by which
you do that addition in other words can
the House and Senate do that without the
president would the president have veto
power of that I don't know the answer to
that and that's sort of like a key thing
that we're gonna be discussing I just
don't know enough about it and I admit
my ignorance I'm not gonna pretend but
it's something that can be done and it's
something that has been done in the past
and it's increasingly being discussed
and the idea being as soon as the rules
allow it whether it's House and Senate
if the Democrats take it over in
November of 2018 inaugurated in January
of 2019 or when Democrats if they ever
do regain control of the White House
whatever the mechanism would be to do
that and of course there would be
outrage there would be conservatives who
absolutely lose their minds Derek but it
is an increasingly discussed strategy so
yes I'm very interested in that right my
concern is of course that the Democrats
don't
I seem to be fighting as much as the
Republicans are and there's gains of the
Republicans are making or just making
the progressive wing really frustrated
with the rest party yep so yeah
this is a problem I Carl yeah I
appreciate it and then generally of
course it's the the question of our
Democrats gonna get it together in
really fight that's an increasing
question that a lot of people are not
feeling very good about and I get why
because it's been horrible and it's not
just fighting to court packing sounds
like it's fighting dirty and I see
definitely an interview about this
coming up in a few weeks with David
Ferris yeah look forward to that yes and
of course if that's not cancelled or we
get a no call no show which does happen
then we will bring at that interview to
you